All right, we'll go ahead and get started.
Thank you all for joining today, this mini symposium.
This is the Pediatric Cancer From Mechanism to Translation.
The speakers were all selected from abstracts that were
submitted,
reviewed by a panel of folks, and then we put them together, and these are our
speakers today here. And so this session really
highlights how advances in developmental biology, tumor ecosystems,
and molecular precision are reshaping therapeutic strategies
for pediatric cancers. Across solid and hematologic
malignancies, the presenters demonstrate how tumor-specific
transcriptional dependencies, cell state plasticity, and
microenvironmental interactions create actionable
vulnerabilities.
Cutting-edge technologies, including spatial profiling, liquid
biopsy, and engineered cellular immunotherapies are
leveraged to move discoveries rapidly from mechanistic
insight to translational application.
Collectively, these studies emphasize a new paradigm
in pediatric oncology, moving beyond cytotoxic
generalization toward biomarker-driven,
context-aware interventions that aim
to maximize durable responses while minimizing the harm to the developing
child.
The session spans immune surveillance and evasion, transcriptional and
epigenetic rewiring, lineage-specific signaling,
and next-generation immunotherapies, underscoring how precision
medicine in pediatrics must be built on a deep understanding of
the developmental context and tumor evolution.
So each of our speakers will be given 15 minutes in total, 10 minutes
for their presentations and five minutes for their questions.
We ask that if you do have questions, please come to the mic so the people online
will be able to hear you. And we look forward to your engagement
in this session. So our first speaker is Adam Durbin from St.
Jude. His talk is entitled Dysregulated AKT
Signaling Reprograms Osteosarcoma to Drive Selective
Reliance on EP300. Adam?
Thanks, Mark, and thanks to the organizers for giving me the opportunity to
speak here today.
Is this... Yeah. Great. Okay.
I have some disclosures related to compounds and systems that we have developed,
some of which I will be discussing today.
For many years now, it's been increasingly aware within the
community that pediatric cancers really are
diseases where mutations tend to show up in conserved
processes, things like transcriptional regulation, epigenetic regulation of
transcription, and three-dimensional chromatin structure.
And so just underscoring that point, here is some
data from Xiaotu Ma's paper in "Nature" from 2018
demonstrating mutations across multiple different pediatric cancer
lineages.
And you can see exactly that point, that these processes tend to
acquire mutations and become oftentimes dysregulated.
And in collaboration with the Pediatric Dependencies Accelerator, and before that
DepMap, my laboratory has been very focused on thinking about
transcriptional regulation through the lens of epigenetics, and we
have dominantly focused on two targets, these master
histone acetyltransferases, P300 and CBP.
Here in this schematic, you can see the domain structure of P300 and
CBP. These are highly paralogous, oftentimes
co-expressed,
lysine acetyltransferases. And these are enzymes.
In the presence of acetyl-CoA, they use this as a cofactor to
acetylate target proteins, including most
famously, histone H3 on lysine 27,
establishing landing spots for bromodomain-containing proteins,
including P300 and CBP,
that form a scaffold to allow for high output target gene expression.
And over the years, we have studied these proteins and
demonstrated that as you look at the DepMap, for
example, you'll find that up to about a quarter of the cell lines in
DepMap are actually uniquely dependent on P300 for survival,
with a smaller fraction being dependent on either CBP or both of these,
suggesting that these are potentially good targets worth going after.
It turns out that it's not just random cell lines.
These are organized into lineages, and so there are lineages, for example,
that have higher dependency on P300 and some that have higher dependency on
CBP and vice versa.
And this type of observation led us several years ago to develop a
small molecule we call JQUAD1. This is a PROTAC that
interacts with the cereblon E3 receptor to drive targeted
protein degradation of P300, sparing CBP.
And the rationale for this compound was that we wanted to target the
dependency,
and we knew if we were going to deliver a systemic therapy, that it might
be best to just target one of these two proteins rather than both,
hoping that the other one would compensate in untransformed
tissues. And testing this in neuroblastoma cells as well as
many others, we demonstrated that it was highly on target against P300, causing
degradation. Along with this, we see loss of
acetylation genome-wide. And this first-generation compound is
well-tolerated in mice and can give you tumor growth
slowing.
So that there you can see some of the toxicity data.
So this led us to the question, are there other lineages or
other tumor types in which targeting P300 might be a nice therapeutic
strategy?
And so together with June Chi's lab at Dana-Farber and Brian Abraham's
lab at St. Jude and Ben Ory's lab at the University of Nantes in France,
we embarked on a DepMap analysisTo try to pull
apart and look for lineages that had selective dependency on p300
relative to CBP. And we paired that with work
in collaboration with the Prism platform at
the Broad Institute, testing these compounds on panels of
bar-coded cell lines, up to about 800 cancer cell lines, to look for
lineages that were particularly sensitive.
And when we fused this data together, what we ended up with,
here looking at some of the top lineages, we found that in comparison to
neuroblastoma, which we knew this compound had nice effects in and was
validated in, that actually osteosarcoma showed up as another
lineage of potential interest.
So I don't really need to introduce osteosarcoma to this audience, but just a
few points to say this is a primary aggressive solid tumor of
bone. We've, over the last decades, not for lack of trying,
have made very limited advancements in drug development.
We currently treat patients with three drugs, methotrexate, doxorubicin, and
cisplatin.
And here's a Kaplan-Meier curve of patients enrolled on a Phase II trials,
and here you can see, of course, we don't do very well.
This is a disease marked by chromothripsis and alternative lengthening of
telomeres. It's very copy number unstable, and there are several molecular
markers that are emerging for this disease to identify groups of
patients who will do particularly poorly, including MYC amplification
and loss of the tumor suppressor PTEN.
And so we partnered with Alejandro Sweet-Cordero's
lab at UCSF. Alejandro's lab has developed these
low-passage, PDX-derived osteosarcoma cell lines that they've
recently demonstrated actually are quite
faithful in terms of recapitulating the patient's primary
tumor. And we tested a panel of these PDX-derived cell lines
using our small molecule and demonstrated that some of these cell lines were
sensitive, while others were not.
And when we looked at the genetics of those cell lines that were quite sensitive,
what we found was that every one of the sensitive lines had a
mutation in it that would've been predicted to hyperactivate the AKT
pathway, either loss of PTEN or amplification of AKT, or
activation of upstream receptor tyrosine kinases.
And so we took some of these cell lines, we tested JQuad on them.
You can see here we're able to deplete p300 with really very
limited effects on CBP. Along with this, we activated apoptosis
parked by cleaved PARP and
lose c-MYC, a driver transcription factor in the disease.
And so this led to two questions, the first being,
is the degrader-driven apoptosis being driven by the loss of c-MYC?
And then the second is, how does AKT dysregulation, is that at all
involved in the sensitivity to this compound?
And so to answer the first question, we took sensitive cell lines, we re-expressed
c-MYC, and then we treated with JQuad, and what we saw was really no rescue of the
phenotype. And so we think that the loss of MYC is actually true to an
unrelated. JQuad is doing something else.
And to answer the second question, we took completely insensitive cell
lines, and we treated them to overexpress myristoylated AKT.
We then treated with JQuad and now at high doses we're able to elicit
some cell death.
And so how does AKT do this? Well, AKT is an upstream
kinase that impacts upon transcriptional regulation, and of course, p300 and
CBP are dominant regulators of transcription, and so we looked at
RNA-seq to start with. And so we took a panel of both sensitive and
insensitive cell lines, as well as our engineered cells, where we
had overexpressed myristoylated AKT and performed RNA-seq.
And we fused this data to look for genes that were upregulated really in
sensitive cells that were under AKT control and identified a group of
genes. And many of these genes that are upregulated, when
we performed ChIP-seq studies, actually now acquired new p300
binding and new enhancer acetylation, and I'm showing you several loci
here. These are dominant
dependencies, genetic dependencies, that are enriched in
AKT-dependent osteosarcomas. So for example,
SLUG, collagen VII, and the MIBL1-BCPIP1 loci.
And it's not just up. Genes go down as well, and those genes that go down also
lose enhancer marking and lose p300 and CBP binding.
And so we think AKT is driving the relocalization of p300 to
new gene loci and in some cases, dependency loci, and that's
really how it's playing its function.
And so if you thought to yourself, these are AKT
dysregulated, so why not just treat with an AKT inhibitor?
Well, there are lots of folks, including some in the audience, who have tried this
before, and the answer is that it slows down tumor growth, but it doesn't actually
involute the tumor. And so we wondered what about co-targeting
p300 and CBP? Would this show some synergy or
additivity? And so we performed
checkerboard synergy assays across all of our PDX lines and
demonstrated
some evidence of either additivity or synergy between p300
degradation, and this tool compound,
MK-2206, which is an AKT inhibitor
in AKT dysregulated cell lines, but not
in other non-AKT dysregulated lines.
And we tested multiple other methods of inactivating p300, and it turns out that
the best way is to use this JQuad1 degrader.
And so is this an osteosarcoma phenomenon, or is this found across cancer?
And so to answer that, we again went back to prism screening, this time performing
prism synergy screens. And so in this case, you treat with a dose response of
MK-2206, or alternatively, you treat with the exact
same dose response, again, in 800 bar-coded cell lines, but in the
presence of JQuad1 at an anchor dose, and we chose a low anchor dose of
JQuad. Here what you're seeing is each individual
line is a different cell line, and if the cell line is red, that means
that it's dying.And so you can see here that an
anchor dose of JQuad alone will cause death of about
somewhere between 10% to 15% of these cells.
And this is what a dose response of MK-2206 looks like.
And then when you put them together, you get something that looks like this,
suggesting additivity or synergy.
We were worried that this was unique to MK-2206, so we used another
AKT inhibitor called capivasertib that recently acquired FDA
approval, and we see the exact same thing.
In fact, if not greater effect with capivasertib.
So how does it work? Well, first we thought there must be a genetic
predictor or a lineage predictor. It turns out that's not true.
And so we rank ordered cell lines by how synergistic or
antagonistic they were. We took the top 100 and bottom 100 of
these most synergistic, most antagonistic, extracted their full
transcriptomes, and then did a hallmarks analysis.
And it turns out that the most synergistic cell lines all show transcriptional
evidence of having AKT signaling being really revved up.
When we looked at KEGG pathways, what we saw was that downstream of this, the
majority of KEGG pathways that were enriched were involved in ribosomal
translation. And so actually, this made a lot of sense.
Here you're using a targeted protein degrader,
and cells that have really, really active
translation, replacing the protein that you're trying to
degrade will be somewhat insensitive.
And so we think what's going on here is that we're using
AKT inhibitors to actually slow down translation, and
that's allowing JQuad to work better.
And so to investigate that, we did some translational synthesis
assays here in a puromycin labeling assay, and you could see that the amount of
protein that's labeled by puromycin in this nascent
translation assay is lower in the sensitive cell lines than it is in the
resistant lines, suggesting that the resistant lines have a higher translational
rate. And then we performed experiments to do
co-treatments and showed that when you co-incubate these two drugs,
that actually your degradation of p300 is vastly improved.
And so lastly, just to leave you with this, we took these
two AKT dysregulated PDXs and we performed
orthotopic xenografts, and then we dialed back the doses of
MK-2206 and JQuad back to about a quarter of
what we would normally use as the MTD.
And what we see is that, of course, these two work quite nicely together in
terms of suppressing tumor volume, prolonging survival.
And in some cases, we were able to do micro CT measurements of tumor
volume. And what we saw was that, of course, the tumors were quite
small in the combination group.
So the key messages that AKT dysregulated osteosarcoma
is sensitive to p300 degradation, that it is
so because of p300 relocalization to new dependency
loci, driving transcriptional reprogramming.
And that these two compounds targeting AKT and
p300 are able to
collaborate to disrupt AKT dysregulated osteosarcoma tumor
growth in vitro and in vivo. And finally, that we think
that this is related to translational signatures.
I'll just acknowledge all the folks in my lab who did the work, who are bolded.
Our collaborators in Brian Abraham's lab, Jun Chi's lab,
Paul Gilaher, Ben Ori, Lily Gunther, and a number of other folks
at the Broad Institute
at St. Jude. And then in addition, folks outside of St.
Jude who have been very helpful along the way.
Our funding sources and you for your attention. Thanks.
All right. We have time for one question.
Hi, Katie Janeway, Dana-Farber. Nice work.
My question for you is really about the drug development future of
something that's a p300
inhibitor or-
Yeah
... degrader.
Yeah.
I'm thinking about toxicity and broader applicability.
Thanks.
Yeah. So I think this is an area that is
quite active with...
Just walk through the poster sessions and you'll see tons of posters about this.
I think there is the question of
what will happen if you go after p300.
And we've looked at a number of different normal
developing tissues in humanized mice.
And when you take out p300 using several different p300 degraders,
you don't see major changes, but of course, you do see some changes.
So I think it's going to be really challenging, and I think that it's going to be
dependent on both the molecule that you're using and the PK
properties of that molecule.
So just to remind everyone, osteosarcoma happens in big people.
They're already grown up. So perfect place to start-
Yeah
... if you're going into a pediatric disease. Thanks.
If there's any drug developers in the audience, please.
Thanks very much, guys.
Our next speaker is Gudrun Schillenbacher.
Did I do well?
Thank you very much for the introduction.
So I'll be speaking about cell-free DNA in relapsed/refractory
neuroblastoma. These are my disclosures.
And as a brief reminder, neuroblastoma is, of course, one of the most
frequent cancers in young children, and we know that in high-risk
disease, after relapse, survival remains dismal
with only poor
treatment options. And in the international European
Neuroblastoma Network, SIOPEN, the BEACON trials proposed
different treatment combinations and enrolled
225 patients with relapsed or refractory neuroblastoma
in 10 countries over eight years. This was a factorial
multi-arm design, and different chemotherapy
backbones were analyzed together, either with
bevacizumab, resulting in a response rate of
30%, or the anti-GD2
dinutuximab beta, resulting in a response rate of
35%. So we learned from this clinical
trial that indeed some activity is observed with
these different combinations independent of the chemotherapy
backbones in this randomized Phase 2 setting.
Furthermore, really distinct clinical evolution patterns in
children with relapsed versus refractory disease were observed.
However, to date, we don't really know the biomarkers of
response.
And so in the biological studies, we now want to address these
questions and first delve into depth to the
genomic alterations of relapsed/refractory neuroblastoma
at the time of enrollment, but also through therapy and relapse,
analyze their evolution, and identify mechanisms of
tumor evolution escape and resistance.
So we based these studies on the samples from
192 patients enrolled in the BEACON trials, also a
control cohort of high-risk neuroblastoma patients
analyzed at diagnosis. For these patients, we could
analyze either tumor samples and then sequential
plasma samples that were collected upon enrollment and
then every two months and at the end of treatment.
Similar samples were collected also in the control cohort.
And we analyzed tumor samples either, when possible, by
tumor and germline whole exome sequencing or by an
extended gene panel. The plasma samples then
served for cell-free DNA extraction.
Overall, 455 plasma samples were analyzed,
a mean of three, one to six per patient, and these were
analyzed by low-coverage whole genome and high-coverage
whole exome sequencing of the cell-free DNA.
Our bioinformatics platform aims to call
tumor-specific versus cell-free DNA-specific
copy number alterations and SNVs.
And first, we want to look more in detail at the tumor-specific
genetic alterations in this population,
highlighting the previously known copy number alterations.
This is no surprise, frequency of 17q gain, and
then also the single gene alterations that we know of, MYCN
amplification, the single gene mutations such as ALK.
We could see that indeed upon relapse, so these are the
relapse samples with relevant alterations and enrichment
as previously described by us and others of ALK
alterations as well as other alterations in the RAS/MAPK kinase
pathways and also a more frequent occurrence of the
recently identified FGFR1 mutations which
confer high aggressivity in these patients.
So following this analysis, we then wanted to look for
prognostic factors that might be associated with outcome
at the time of enrollment in BEACON.
Patients with refractory disease fared better than those in
relapse. MYCN amplification is associated with poorer
outcome in these patients. However, the presence of ALK mutations
or mutations in the RAS/MAPK kinase pathways were not
associated with poorer outcome upon enrollment in BEACON.
We then looked more in detail at analyses of cell-free DNA,
focusing first on the overall cell-free DNA quantity
at the time of enrollment. We can see really a very
vast
range of cell-free DNA concentrations from 10 to over
1,000 nanograms per mil of plasma.
This did not correlate with overall disease burden as
evaluated by the SIOP and MIBG score, as you can
see here. However, a prognostic impact of the overall
cell-free DNA quantity at enrollment in the BEACON trials
was observed. Those with a cell-free DNA above the cutoff fared
worse.
We then looked at the cell-free DNA in our sequential analyses,
looking both at cell-free DNA quantity and the ctDNA content.
We see that in BEACON, at the time of relapse or
progression, lower quantities at the time of diagnosis are observed,
and then in the follow-up samples every two months, we see,
correlating with the response, decrease and then again
increase at the end of treatment. And this is reflected in these
different patient graphs where we can see these distinct
dynamics, either of decrease and then stable persistence
of cell-free DNA, a complete eradication, or eradication
and then reappearance correlating with the disease
course.Our cell-free DNA whole exome
sequencing then enables us to call all SNVs that are
termed tumor specific, filtered on the germline, and
this gives us further detail on the different dynamics of the different
mutations that we can observe with different patterns
according to the different patients.
Now, we wanted to analyze this more in detail, and we
calculated the cancer cell fraction for each of the
SNVs based not only on the variant allele fraction
but also on purity of the sample, ploidy, and copy
number state. And this enables us then to identify cellular
clones, which can then, in the different models,
identify clones determined by the different
SNVs. And we can see as an example here, the distinct
evolution of the different clones in a given patient with disappearance
of one cellular clone at the follow-up sample and emergence of
others.
If we look more in detail at the genes targeted by these SNVs, we
can see that those observed in cell-free
DNA only frequently target genes which
code for proteins important in cell-to-cell or
cell-to-extracellular matrix
interactions. Cell-free DNA SNVs that
disappear upon treatment
frequently concern molecular transducers, whereas
those that emerge during treatment target,
amongst others, the RAS MAP kinase pathways.
And interestingly, we saw that frequently,
HRAS or other RAS MAP kinase genes like to
remain at a subclonal level, whereas other SNVs have really become
clonal.
Importantly, in some instances, we observed alterations in
genes that are known to actually occur during clonal
hematopoiesis, as in this example, a mutation in JAK3
observed with low VAF in the cell-free DNA.
We looked at the PBMC at the time and saw that indeed
after treatment, this mutation was present in the cells at
6%. Of note, this mutation was not
identified at diagnosis for this patient, neither in the tumors nor in the
PBMC, allowing us to conclude that this probably does
correspond to clonal hematopoiesis.
Further analysis is ongoing to determine the frequency of these events in our
population. And finally, we want to study gene
expression and infer gene expression from our cell-free
DNA data. And in this context, it is important to
remember that actually when cell-free DNA is
released into the bloodstream, the actual fragment size
depends upon the cleavage that depends upon the nucleosome
positioning. And at transcription start sites for genes that are
expressed, the well-defined nucleosome organization results
then in dips upon the sequencing, whereas in less expressed
genes, this results in a higher overall coverage.
And we leverage this for a unique experimental design where we
designed a capture across 34,000 transcription start sites,
which we sequenced to a high depth across 200
base pairs to the right and to the left of each of these.
We then used machine learning to train our results with regards to
coverage on the GTEx database to call expressed versus
non-expressed genes. And then we used this on our
targeted
TSS regions in neuroblastoma plasma samples.
Here are some examples when we do k-means clustering, and we can
identify genes that are commonly predicted as
being silent, as indicated here, AKT, or commonly
expressed genes such as ALK and TERT in the overall
population. We also identified genes with
distinct expression predicted, such as this one in
MYCN amplified versus these in MYCN
non-amplified cases. In our context and the BEACON
trial, we then thought it was important to look at these predicted gene
expressions comparing the samples from diagnosis
to relapse. And here again, in addition to the genes
that are commonly predicted to be not expressed, so with high
coverage or expressed with low coverage, we could identify
clusters that were initially silent and then became
expressed at relapse, such as STAT6 or FOXP1,
or on the other hand, that were initially expressed and then became
silent, such as BCORL1 and ARID5B.
So altogether, we show in these BEACON
biological studies an overall
context of genetic alterations, but importantly, the
prognostic impact of MYCN amplification in this study.
No correlation between the cell-free DNA quantity and the SIOPEN
score was observed, but we did see that cell-free DNA was of
prognostic impact. The whole exome sequencing
provides further evidence of clonal evolution, and further data
analysis is ongoing to really identify the most frequent clones that
emerge at the time of relapse. And we can really
distinguish those that disappear versus those that emerge
during treatment. We are currently finalizing
analyses to determine the frequency of clonal
hematopoiesis. We have a hint that that might occur
with temozolomide treatment, which we use a lot in Europe, but that's ongoing.
And we are working on integrating our inferred
expression profiles with the genetic information.
I would like to thank all collaborators.
This work was done in my team by Yasmine Idir, Charles Bobin, Alexandre
Saint-Chal, and I would like to thank Sally George, Lucas
Morena, Lou Chesler, and everybody who contributed to the
study, and importantly, patients and their families. Thank you very much.
Thank you, Adrienne. That was
beautiful data and very well delivered. Thank you.
It
was very clever with the nucleosome and differential expression, and you showed the
extremes where not expressed and then high expressed.
I just wonder if you've looked at things like
mechanisms of resistance, and have you looked at the GD2 synthesis
enzymes or-
Yeah
... things along those pathways?
I must admit that this is preliminary data, and we're currently working on that.
I had thought we'd be further along the way looking at such aspects,
and we took a bit of delay due to a maternity leave of the
bioinformatician, and that's-
Congratulations, Gudrun.
Well, not me. It's the bioinformatician.
But hopefully
we'll be able to pick that up, and I agree that that's a very important aspect to
work on.
Yeah.
Thanks, John.
I actually have a question about the kinetics of the cell-free DNA.
I've always wondered, in the middle of treatment-- You said at the beginning, at
diagnosis, it is reflective, potentially prognostic.
But I've always wondered, in the middle of treatment, does your data demonstrate
anything regarding the kinetics of cell-free DNA and response?
I think that's a very important question, and what we're currently working on is
correlating that with the clinical data. That is also ongoing.
And so we retrieve detailed clinical data, including,
for us in Europe, the MIBG score, to match that with the actual
cell-free DNA data, and I think that will provide more insight.
And I think as we move along, we'll be able to integrate that and maybe pick
out the patients that need continuing treatment indeed.
Thanks.
Thank you.
One more question. So it was interesting about the
patterns of the clones that you were finding-
Yeah
... in the cell-free DNA. And so was there dominant
patterns of clones that you were seeing across-
Yeah
... many, many
children that you could--
Yeah.
With all the-
So again, we frequently see clones that harbor
RAS/MAP kinase mutations or ALK, and
interestingly, those, even though we think they are driver genes,
and many in this room have studied these for a long time,
they somehow like to remain at a subclonal level
associated with many other genes.
So we're currently working on that, trying to figure out a model.
I don't know why these tumors then like this
heterogeneity. It's like an ecosystem of different cells
that need to work together, and I think these data
provide some insight into that and will need further modelization.
Great. Thank you.
Thanks.
Our next speaker is January Zhang from Princess Margaret Cancer
Centre in Toronto. Her talk is entitled "Spatial T Cell Receptor
Profiling Uncovers Barriers to T Cell Engagement and Shared
Tumor-Reactive Clonotypes in High-Risk Neuroblastoma."
Awesome. Thanks for the introduction. Hi, everyone.
My name is January. I'm a PhD candidate from the University of
Toronto, and today we'll present our work with the Children's Oncology
Group on how spatially resolved T cell receptor tracking links tumor
immune segregation to T cell
clonotype-specific states in high-risk neuroblastoma.
And I have no disclosures.
High-risk neuroblastoma, or HR-NB, is the most frequent extracranial
solid tumor in children and typically occurs in the adrenal gland.
Despite very intensive standard of care, including induction
chemotherapy, consolidative stem cell transplant, and
post-consolidation anti-GD2 therapy, the five-year survival
rate remains at only about 50%. These limited outcomes have
driven increasing interest in the role of the immune system, particularly
T cells, in shaping disease progression and therapeutic
response.
T cells are specialized immune cells that act as one of the body's
primary defense against cancer.
Each T cell has a unique heterodimeric T cell receptor, or
TCR, that allows the cell to recognize and bind to
specific antigens.
In neuroblastoma, conventional alpha beta T cells are detected but
functionally constrained due to the downregulation of
antigen-presenting molecules.
This has therefore drawn attention to gamma delta T cells, which recognize
their targets independent of these molecules.
However, the actual contribution of these T cells and their TCRs
remain largely undefined.
So using samples from the AMBL1531 trial, we
assembled a cohort with longitudinal sampling across 11
clinical time points.
So this Phase 3 clinical trial tests the efficacy of the
radiopharmaceutical 131I-MIBG, which could
potentially modulate antitumor immunity through enhanced
antigen
availability and altered T cell activation.
In this trial, patients are randomized into either standard therapy or
standard therapy plus I-MIBG, and currently we are still
blinded, so we don't know which patient is assigned to which arm.
So the cohort I want to focus on today includes paired tumor
FFPEs from initial diagnostic biopsy and
subsequent surgical resection from five HR-NB patients.
Additionally, we also have matching blood samples, including
PBMC and cell-free DNA, whenever they were available.
So we first performed bulk TCR sequencing on our entire
cohort,
for TCR chains alpha, beta, gamma, and delta, which
resulted in more than 10 million reads per sample for our tumor,
cell-free DNA, and PBMC.
Then from the bulk data, we selected 100 TCR
clonotypesAnd developed custom Xenium probes
for spatial tracking.
And combining these with 377 additional Xenium gene
probes for cell identity, we were able to profile the
10 FFP tumors, allowing us to achieve in-situ
localization of specific TCR
clonotypes, linking specific TL states to their
exact physical location.
So our approach yielded
high-resolution single-cell profiling of over two million cells.
We found seven major cell types,
including neural blast cells,
macrophages, B cells, and T cells.
And right off the bat, we observed compartmentalization across the different cell
types, so we decided to perform a series of distance
analyses.
And so the first
experiment we did was a co-occurrence analysis, which
quantified which cell types are clustering together and which are being pushed
apart. And across all samples, we
observed robust self-association of the B and T cells, as
shown by the circled red columns on the left,
as well as on the right, where you can see T cells in black and B
cells in maroon clustering together.
Conversely, T and B cells are consistently depleted
near neural blasts, as shown by the circled blue columns on the left
and also on the right, where the yellow neural blast cells are segregated
from the immune cells.
Next, we asked which, if any, T cell subtypes were
able to
bypass the segregation. So we performed a
neighbor analysis, which calculated the cell type
identity for each T cell's top 10 nearest neighbors.
And we found that gamma delta T cells have the highest proportion of
neural blast neighbors, with neural blasts accounting for
45% of their immediate environment.
So this highlights gamma delta T cells as a spatially
privileged population, capable of localized
interactions with neural blast cells.
Next, shifting from single-cell to tissue-level organization,
cellular domain analysis identified distinct spatial
domains. And again, we found that gamma delta T cells are
highly enriched in neural blast-rich domains, as shown by the
prominent dark blue segment in the center of this chart.
So this demonstrates the selective recruitment or
retention of
gamma delta T cells to the tumor
microenvironment.
Finally, comparing the gene expression of T cells located
in different domains, we found that T cells
in neural blast-rich domains have a higher expression of the exhaustion marker
LAG3, whereas those in immune-rich domains have a higher
expression of CD4 and the activation marker Fos.
Next, shifting to specific TCR clones,
our bulk analysis identified several cross-patient TCRs that we
prioritized for spatial tracking.
And one prominent example is gamma clone 2,
detected across a PBMC, cell-free DNA, and tumor of six
patients and 10 samples across our entire cohort
with the 11 clinical time points.
By visualizing this clone in our primary Xenium data set, we can
see that gamma clone 2 positive T cells, colored in maroon, are
distributed throughout the tissue of two patients and three
samples within our FFP cohort.
And zooming in on the exact physical location of gamma clone 2,
represented by blue T cells with magenta dots inside, you
can see that this clone is frequently located adjacent to yellow
neural blast cells. So this physical proximity,
again, indicates that this gamma clone
is able to infiltrate neural blast-rich
domains.
Finally, we assessed
whether the phenotype of this gamma clone 2
differs across different spatial domains.
And we found that clone 2-positive cells located
in immune-rich
regions
maintains a more progenitor-like
phenotype with higher expression of markers like TCF7 and
L7R, whereas those located in neural blast-rich
domains have a more terminally exhausted phenotype with markers
like KLRD1 and TOX.
Finally, our platform extends beyond gamma delta T cells to conventional
alpha beta T cells. Because the TCR is a
heterodimer, but bulk sequencing loses chain pairing, we use a
co-detection of both an alpha and a beta
probe within the same cell to identify alpha beta pairs.
And here I'm showing one example, including alpha clone
45 and beta clone 64. And as you can see on the right,
both of these clones have been repeatedly detected within the same cells.
And similarly, this clone also exhibits a more terminally differentiated
phenotype
within neural blast-rich regions.
We also have a few predictions for the antigen specificity of this
clone, one of them being the cancer testis antigen
NY-ESO-1, and that is present.
This antigen is detected on about
23% of all neuroblastoma tumors.
But of course, that would require further experimental validation before we
have a definitive answer.
Oh, sorry.
So in summary, our work demonstrates that tumor immune
segregation is a defining feature of HRMB, and that gamma delta
T cells are a spatially privileged populationThat is
able to infiltrate immune-rich environments.
Sorry, neuroblast-rich environments.
And we also found that T-cell's transcriptional state is
driven by location rather than by clonotype identity alone in
HRMB. Going forward, we are transitioning from
Xenium to Visium HD on fresh frozen tissue, which
will enable the shift from targeted discovery to an
unbiased whole transcriptome in situ localization
of the entire TCR repertoire.
So with that, I would like to thank the AACR for the opportunity to present this
work,
as well as the Department of Defense and CIHR for funding
this project. And of course, this research would not have been possible
without the incredible support of the Pu Lab, as well as our amazing
collaborators.
The manuscript for this work is currently undergoing internal review
at the Children's Oncology Group and will soon be published as a preprint.
And finally, I'd like to thank the audience for your attention today.
Yeah, feel free to ask any questions now, or you can also reach out to me online.
Thank you so much.
Hi. Congratulations. John Anderson from University College
London.
You've found a really interesting clone.
I guess you don't know what the delta pairing of that's likely to be yet, and I
wondered if you'd identified any clonotypes yet in the
blood samples you've also looked at and been able to correlate them to any of the
tumor-specific clonotypes.
Right. Thank you for your question.
So unfortunately, we were not able to pair any gamma delta
clones, and so
apparently that is a very common issue in TCR work.
I was hoping to pair them in my work, but that didn't happen.
We did find
quite a few interesting blood clonotypes.
Some of them have an antigen. Some of them have a
CDR3 sequence that is very similar to
viral epitopes. And I also found a few
CDR3 regions that are exclusively in neuroblastoma
patients. Unfortunately, we found them after designing this
Xenium panel, so we're not able to track them
spatially. And that's why we are transitioning to
Visium HD,
which don't require probes anymore.
So yeah, that's the next step. Thank you.
Beautiful presentation. Thank you.
Thank you.
I know you guys do a lot of things besides neuroblastoma in Trevor's lab, so can
you just talk a little bit about how this compares specifically, the
gamma delta observation? Is this
common across cancers, or is this something that's unique in neuroblastoma?
Right. Thank you for your question.
So
there's recent evidence in neuroblastoma.
There's this paper published not a long time ago.
And they said that gamma delta T-cells are the primary
antitumor effector cell in neuroblastoma, and so
my work,
we kind of confirmed that. These are the
only two evidence in neuroblastoma with gamma delta T-cells that I can
find.
I know that we've been working with
other groups like the Ohashi lab. They are a huge believer
of gamma delta T-cells. They think these are very potent
antitumor
T-cells, and so personally, I believe in gamma delta
T-cells too.
But in adult malignancies, do you see that the gamma deltas are also
more tumor specific than alpha beta, or is this unique in
neuroblastoma?
Oh, interesting. I personally only work with
pediatric data, but our
collaborators are working with adult data, and they
seem to be very interested in the gamma delta T-cells, so we believe it could
be the next big thing.
Yeah, I agree. Thank you.
Thank you.
So thank you very much. First of all, congratulations.
Absolutely beautiful data.
Did you have the chance to functionally test the receptors?
Sorry, could you repeat your question?
Right. So unfortunately, no. Currently,
our estimates are based on bioinformatic tools.
We ran a tool called Mixed TCR Pred, which gave
us the idea that maybe this clone is specific to
NY-ESO-1.
But my work is primarily dry lab based, and we're
currently looking for collaborators to verify these
predictions for us. And we're also trying to set
up experiments that would do that ourselves, but I think that would take some time,
maybe a year.
This could be such beautiful training sets to...
This is kind of the Holy Grail. You want to pick that cell that is responsive
versus the bystander, so.
Exactly. Thank you so much.
I have one question, which is
I noticed that you also see regulatory T-cells in your data set, and I'm just
curious, do those also colocalize, and how did
they differ between the diagnostic and the resection samples?
Right. So,
in one of the
graphs that I showed, Tregs
also have a very high frequency of neuroblast neighbors.
So I believe it's 42%.
Unfortunately, we didn't find any TCR clonotypes that are the
Tregs. We mostly found CD8 clonotypes.
And so yeah, I didn't look further into it, but that's a great idea.
I think I can look into it. Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Our next speaker is Patrick Scheuer, who is from the Children's Hospital of
Philadelphia. He'll be giving a talk, "Co-targeting
GPC2 and B7H3 with CAR T cells achieves durable
responses in preclinical high-risk neuroblastoma and medulloblastoma
models."
All right. Thank you, everybody, for selecting this abstract for
presentation.
Oh, yeah. The only
disclosure I have is a patent in relation to a talk I gave yesterday about
CHR3 CAR T cells.
But I'm going to dive right in. So for the ones who are familiar with the work of
my boss, Chris Bosse,
he co-discovered GPC2 on neuroblastoma
tumors, and this has been shown to be now a great target in
neuroblastoma, but also other solid tumors, brain tumors, and other
neuroendocrine tumors. And this has all culminated in
two exciting ongoing clinical trials, one at the East Coast at CHOP and
one here at the West Coast at Stanford, again, for solid and brain
tumors.
And all of this is obviously super encouraging.
However, what we do see in our pre-clinical models
is that GPC2 downregulation is routinely
observed under CAR T cell pressure.
So in the past, we have tried different next-generation CAR T
cell constructs, including GPC2/GD2 biases.
And this time we thought we go back to a more simpler
architecture and also go for dual CAR T cells, given that this has
been used successfully also by others.
And we settled on B7H3 as a
second target, given that it's still high in relapsed
tumors that are low for GPC2. And in addition to that, in
neuroblastoma, B7H3 is also high on all
cell states.
So long story short, we, similar to others, just did
bicistronic CAR T cells with a GPC2 CAR and a
B7H3 CAR linked together. And there was
this cool
publication by the Dotti group showing that you can actually omit
the CD3 zeta domain from the
downstream CAR, and this improves the CAR T-cell
fitness and anti-tumor response in these models.
So we also included these CARs, which we just call parallel CARs.
And then in addition to that, we also included more control groups such as double
transduced control groups, co-infused control groups, and of course,
the single CARs. And then we did a bunch of in vitro
and in vivo assays, and I'm just going to pick out some highlights of the work that
we did.
So we mainly focused on neuroblastoma and medullo
coming from our collaborators.
This is one of the isogenic cell line screens we did with
Nalm6, that are one of the few cells that are double negative for those
antigens. And we used the Jurkat mFET reporter system,
and then picked CARs based on
activation. And
we settled for one dual CAR that showed great activation in
presence of one or both antigens and also prioritized one of
the parallel CARs for further investigation.
So then we took the prioritized dual CAR1 and parallel
CAR2. We did some more in vitro QC-ing, and this
is an example of an in vitro
restim assay that we did. And you can see basically GFP tumor
cells can grow out. And we have great
efficacy from the dual and parallel CARs
shown here in blue, and obviously those outperform the
GPC2 CAR that is currently in the clinic, which is this G-CAR here,
which is this green line here. And also those CARs
were outcompeting also the dual transduced and co-infused groups.
And something that was encouraging to see is also that those dual and parallel CARs
kept secreting cytokines also after multiple secretions, as
shown here.
This is just to show that we also did some phenotyping on those T cells at the
different restims and also looked at exhaustion markers, and that
further convinced us that the D1 and P2 CARs
are superior.
So then we moved this in vivo. This is an example of a
neuroblastoma model we used. Again, here the CAR that
we use in the clinic is shown on the top left.
So unfortunately, all those mice do relapse.
Same for the single B7H3 CAR. We did have some cured mice, but also
most mice did relapse.
And on the bottom you can see basically the bicistronic CARs doing a great
job in controlling the tumor and keeping the mice cured, and same
for the co-transduced group.
However, we did see that there is some value in doing bicistronic
architecture over co-transduction, given that we had a better T cell
proliferation in the D and P2 groups.
Also, something we learned from this model is that CAR T cell
trafficking might not be a reason for relapse given that those tumors were
full of T cells. And in addition to that, when we checked the bone marrow of the
cured mice, we detected still a lot of T cells that were in there, and we
hypothesized that those T cells could protect these mice from
tumor rechallenge.
And then this is what we did in the next model.
This is again neuroblastoma,
again with a single CAR in the clinic shown on the top left.
And basically, this dotted line represents the time point of
restim, but you can see that the GPC2 CAR fails already
before even making it to a second round.
Also, most of the B7H3 CARs relapsed in the
first tumor round.
We did have a few cured mice, but you can see here after restim,
interestingly, T cells expanded in the periphery but did not control the
tumor.
In contrast, we saw again that the dual
bicistronic CARs did a great job. We had a great early expansion of T
cells andMost, if not all, of the mice were cured
in the first round. And you can see also this is obviously very zoomed
out, but this is
36 weeks, so the mice were protected from tumor rechallenge
and either remained cured or showed very late relapses.
And then this one also shows that, again, there is some value in going for a
bicistronic CAR, even though it is more work than just co-transducing.
But you can see here that the co-transduction and co-infusion groups
fared not as well as the bicistronic
constructs.
So what else did we learn? We learned also that when we bled
these mice, we saw again, like in the first model, a superior T cell expansion of
the bicistronic CARs. Bicistronic CAR T cells also secreted
the better cytokines and also more of them.
We also saw that GPC2 CARs associated with a high IL-2 level
in the serum, which is unfavorable.
And at the same time, when we looked at those double cured mice,
the double survivors, we basically again saw that the T cells were still persisting
in the bone marrow as TCM and TEMs and could
potentially protect these mice
from a further rechallenge.
Then next, we
looked at the endpoint tumors, and what you can see here down below is
that also in the co-transduced group, we saw a bad tumor
infiltration.
And in addition to that, we also saw that in the co-transduced group, those T cells
expressed higher levels of PD-1 when we
isolated those from the endpoint tumors.
And then not surprisingly, kind of linking back to what I said at the intro, we saw
that GPC2 was downregulated in all groups.
And in contrast, B7-H3 remained very stable
throughout all treatment groups, whether first or second-round cured mice
or relapse mice.
Then, as I said, most bicistronic-treated mice were
cured, and in the few mice that relapsed with bicistronic CARs, we
saw a high MDSC infiltration, and this also confirms
what we and others have seen, that basically MDSCs do
infiltrate into these tumors and suppress CAR function.
Then this is something we did with our collaborators from the Laura Donovan
group and her postdoc, Ben Draper.
They used the Met211 medulloblastoma
model, and you can see, again, this is the GPC2 CAR
that's currently in the clinics for neuroblastoma, and you can see that
most mice relapse early. There is definitely
B7-H3-driven killing going on.
Something we don't understand is that the dual CAR is relapsing
or a lot of mice treated with a dual CAR relapse, whereas the best CAR seems to
be, again, this parallel CAR-2.
And then we confirmed this together with the Jess Foster group.
He helped me out with the surgeries, and then I just tracked these mice on the
IVIS. And again, you can see this is the GPC2-treated
mice. Again, all of them relapse early, whereas
B7-H3-treated mice,
there's definitely a B7-H3 heavy
killing. And again, we had some relapses in the dual one group.
And similar to our previous models, we saw
that the parallel CARs did the best job at controlling
the medullo tumors.
I
checked in the bone marrow again, saw persisting T cells.
And obviously, we gave those T cells into their brain, but they
traffic to the bone marrow and remain there.
We did not do rechallenge experiments for the medullo model.
And then down here, we're also interested in whether those tumors
downregulate GPC2 or not. But as you can see here,
GPC2 expression is very heterogeneous to begin with in these
models which made it hard for us to really observe a
downregulation or not.
And as the last slide,
we're motivated to test this in other tumors.
This is a sarcoma. Again, B7-H3-driven
killing, a lot of early relapses,
but then these early relapses are reduced in the double
one or bicistronic CAR-treated group.
So with that, I would like to close.
We conclude that bicistronic CAR T cells are superior to
single or co-transduced or co-infused CAR T cells.
And this kind of supports also what other groups have shown
previously. And, yeah, with that, I would like
to thank my mentor, Chris Bosse, past
and present members of the Bosse Group, our collaborators from
the Donovan Group, and the Foster Group and Maris Group, and
thank you so much for your attention.
Thank you. Lindsay Talbot, St. Jude. That was great.
I just wanted to ask very briefly, have you or are you planning to try this
strategy in an immune-competent model of any of these tumors?
Yeah, that's a good question. We could definitely do that with the B7-H3
binder that we use, given that it does bind or recognize also
murine B7-H3.
We do have a murine GPC2 CAR,
but we have not so far done a dual GPC2
B7-H3 binder. But our B7-H3 binder would definitely allow for that, and that's
definitely something that we could do and which would obviously
also allow us to dive a bit deeper in this whole MDSC
phenomena that we have seen in the PDX models.
Patrick. Kim Stegmaier from Dana-Farber. Really nice work.
Question on what is known about how GPC2 is
regulated and what's leading to the downregulation in the context of the CAR
pressure?
Yeah, it's a great question. I mean, soFirst of all,
MYCN does drive GPC2 overexpression. That is known.
We have another postdoc, Xue-Ting Li, who is trying a
CRISPR screen to really nail down what are the pathways that
are activated to down-regulate GPC2.
I don't want to steal her thunder too much, but what she's basically seeing is that
a lot of... So what we did is we co-cultured target cells and GPC2 CAR
T-cells. She did the CRISPR screen, and we saw that a lot of
pathways that are involved in the GPI anchoring, also the
trafficking of GPC2 through the cell surface, are affected.
In addition to that, also, heparan sulfate residues seem
to affect binding of the
binders that we are using.
Really interesting.
There will be more to come from our lab, I guess, on that soon.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Patrick, thank you for that nice talk.
You mentioned that
B7H3 is expressed across both the adrenergic and mesenchymal
cell states. You see GPC2 solo
and B7H3 alone. You see better responses with
B7H3. And then I'm curious if you've looked or are
planning to look for the cell states that are in the relapse clone,
the things that grow out. Does that track?
What comes out of the GPC2 alone, B7H3 alone, and the combo?
Yeah. No, that is a great question. That is something that we are looking into.
So just to go back one step, we do definitely see that GPC2
gets down-regulated in the mesenchymal cell state, whereas B7H3 is
high on both cell states. This also kind of goes back to a Robbie Meister paper,
right? Showing that there is the Maputal publication showing
that GD2 therapy can be circumvented like that.
And I did submit IHC right before going to AACR, so
we're going to look at those tumors and look for PHOX2B and
other markers. And I don't know. Our hypothesis could be that
those tumors could be more mesenchymal.
Great. Stay tuned.
All right. Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
All right. Our next speaker is Sheila Xing from McMaster University
in Ontario, and the title of her talk is
Surface-localized Nuclear Envelope Proteins Define
Therapeutic Vulnerability in MYC-Driven Group 3
Medulloblastoma.
Thank you. Good afternoon, everyone, and thank you to the organizers for
the opportunity to give this talk.
So these are my disclosures.
We all know in the room that medulloblastoma is the most common malignant
pediatric brain tumor, and it's comprised of four distinct subgroups,
but they're uniformly all treated with maximally safe surgical resection followed
by chemoradiotherapy. And with this intensive regimen, we've seen an
increase in the five-year overall survivorship to almost 80%.
But our lab focuses on the most aggressive subtypes of medulloblastoma,
namely MYC-driven Group 3, in which the survival rates fall below 50%.
And these patients almost always fail to respond to standard of care and face
disease relapse, which is the worst complication of medulloblastoma
treatment. And while there exist many challenges to translating the
success of CAR T-cell therapies into solid tumors,
we really think antigen selection faces unique barriers in pediatric tumors
compared to their adult counterparts because of the result of somatic
mutations, and high mutational burden, and also
fewer neoantigens. And there are also challenges in finding persistent
or recurrent specific markers that are not lost through
treatment, through standard of care.
And as always, of course, the challenges of on-target/off-tumor talks.
And so to identify potential targets, we analyzed our in-house
proteomics data set of chemotherapy-resistant metastatic
MYC-driven Group 3 medulloblastoma cell lines, and we prioritized the
top 25% most abundant proteins from over 9,000 total
proteins by their differential expression between normal
cells and medulloblastoma cell expression.
And when we subsequently screened for proteins that were transmembrane,
we identified these nuclear envelope proteins as our top candidates.
And of course, these would not have been detected by a canonical CAR T-cell target
discovery pipeline.
So profiling our MYC-driven Group 3 medulloblastoma cell lines identified very
abundant LBR and TMPO expression across Group 3
medulloblastoma, with more ubiquitous expression of TMPO across normal
in Group 4 medullo. And notably, LBR expression was closely
linked to c-MYC expression and elevated specifically in our
MYC-amplified Group 3 medulloblastoma compared to normal neural
stem cells, normal human astrocytes, and indeed, all of the other
medulloblastoma subgroups.
So we went on to do some really beautiful high-resolution
microscopy with our colleagues, Jorge and Giedre Kair ensiuite
at St. Jude Children's Hospital. And
you can see here that there's really LBR and TMPO
co-localization to the nuclear envelope, to the endoplasmic
reticulum, and also to the plasma membrane, again, really only in the Group
3 medulloblastoma cells. And flow cytometry also shows that
only LBR and TMPO co-localize with the plasma membrane.
In the neural stem cells, these nuclear
envelope proteins did not significantly correlate to the plasma membrane
markers. And really, we thought this highlights an
untapped therapeutic opportunity where
this is tucked inside normal cells safely, but it's overexpressed and on the
surface of Group 3 medulloblastoma.
And so we did some orthogonal validation of these
proteins with TIRF microscopy imaging, which showed the same
results that I've described to you on the previous
slide.And then to truly validate our cell surface
finding and with help from the Jason Moffatt Lab at SickKids, we generated MYC
group 3 medulloblastoma cell lines that were endogenously tagged with either halo
or mNeon tags through CRISPR-Cas9 genome editing
such that all the LBR proteins expressed in our patient-derived lines were tagged
at the N-termini. And then we used an impermeable cell dye such that only
cell surface-exposed LBR will produce a true plasma membrane-associated
signal.
So now that we've... And we actually went to also look through
this beautiful proteomic data set from our colleagues in the Poul Sorensen lab,
and you can see that LBR is also a prognostic marker for medulloblastoma
patients, and importantly, it's significantly enriched at recurrence
or post-therapy.
And in fact, when we put mice through our
therapy-adapted models in the lab, you can see that these patient-derived
xenograft mice treated with
the ACNS 0935 therapy protocol
actually enrich the expression of LBR through therapy.
So now that we've thoroughly validated the exclusive presentation of these nuclear
envelope proteins on the surface of group 3 medulloblastoma cells and not on normal
cells, we can now convince our antibody engineers that a therapeutic approach is
warranted. And so this led to a campaign for the rational development of
second-generation CAR T cells targeting LBR and TMPO for the
treatment of MYC-driven group 3 medulloblastoma.
And our wonderful antibody engineers, Kevin Henry and Martin Risotti from
NRC, started with the generation of some in-house camelid
single-domain antibodies.
And here you can see we carried out an extensive campaign to pick the most
sensitive and specific clones before cloning the best binders into our
second-generation CAR T-cell backbone.
And in all of the cases, we found that the single domain antibodies against LBR,
the SCFVs against LBR, and the single domain antibodies against
TMPO, all cloned into CAR T cells, showed efficacy
at 4:1 E:T ratios, and they cleared tumors both in
vitro and in vivo, which I'll expand on
later. Meanwhile, back at the lab,
our MD-PhD student, Yujin Suk, who is the
primary author on all of this work...
And I forgot to mention at the beginning that this work is unpublished, so please
don't post.
Yujin basically wanted to examine the proliferative capacity of LBR positive
and LBR negative sorted medulloblastoma cells.
And you can see here that she found that the LBR positive cells are highly, highly
enriched in all of the cell cycle pathways when we did RNA
sequencing on those cells. And here you can see that the LBR
negative cells remain in G1 when we did cell cycle analysis, but the LBR
positive cells are the continually very, very highly cycling
populations. And I'll remind everyone, of course, that when you send a quick
section for medulloblastoma from the OR, the pathologist will report
back how highly proliferated it is.
And obviously, sometimes we see Ki-67s very alarmingly of up to
97% or 98%.
Back at the University of Toronto, Karim Mikhael had published this beautiful
paper on DNA double-strand break capturing nuclear envelope
tubules,
more colloquially known as DSB NETs.
And these DSB NETs seem to drive DNA repair, and this piqued our interest
because he had studied everything in triple-negative breast cancer lines
which aren't nearly as proliferative as the medulloblastoma cells I just mentioned.
So we know that DNA double-strand breaks can move to the nuclear periphery for
repair, and human nuclear envelope localizes to the double-strand
breaks in a manner depending on DNA damage response kinases and cytoplasmic
microtubules. So in this paper, Mikhael showed that the factors
collaborate with link proteins, nuclear pore complex proteins,
nuclear lamina, and kinesin engines, and with
LBR to generate these DSB capturing
nuclear envelope tubules or DSB NETs, which seem to be critical factors in
genome organization and stability.
So considering the very high DNA damage level and nuclear deformations in
cancer, as shown here when we stained our lines with P53
and other DDR proteins, we hypothesized that DSB NETs could mediate
the repair of accumulating DNA damage and optimize repair protein
engagement and promote non-homologous end joining.
So we turned to Dr. Ray Truant and Dr.
Carlos Baba at the COM Imaging Facility at McMaster University, who
used super-resolution microscopy
in order to stain our cells for LBR in green.
You can see lamin B in magenta, and the DNA is in blue.
And what we see here is that there's severe membrane invaginations, which we think
really resembled the Mikhael paper's photos of DSB NETs.
And there's microtubular retraction causing fracturing of the nuclear membrane.
So fragments of the nuclear membrane bearing LBR can be thrown up to the plasma
membrane, where there seems to be an inside-out fusion that happens.
The double-strand break repair is high, so the DSB NET activity is
high, and there's a great chance of nuclear envelope damage upon
microtubular retraction, which nets membrane fragments that end up on the plasma
membrane, fusing inside out. And the LBR pulls apart from the
nucleus from prophase to anaphase when the nuclear envelope breaks down, and in
telophase, the nuclear envelope membrane is very stressed and
fractured. So here you can see the LBR at the cell
membrane and in the cytoplasm, and it's marked here in purple in
these beautiful images. So the 3D images are striking.
LBRs are at the cell surface, and those invaginations go right
through the nucleus. And you can really see this invagination
pattern shows a structurally stressed nucleus because of double-strand
breaks matched with higher rates of mitosis.
This gives a better chance of membrane fragmentation.So back to the
targeting strategy now. We think we may have
uncovered a mechanism by which LBR is aberrantly mislocalized to
the plasma membrane. Now we want to target it.
So what we see here is that we know that single antigen targeting CAR T
cells that we generated here show efficacy both in vitro and in
vivo. So you can see quite good efficacy.
But remember, LBR and TMPO are not highly expressed, any
single one of them. So to generate more potent CAR T cell therapies, we
decided to tackle both the antigen density issues and persistence challenges, which
are not mutually exclusive. And we generated bispecific CARs,
combining the single domain antibodies of our most promising LBR and
TMPO binders, and we validated their potency in vitro,
and then we were able to see very durable and
better remission in the dual targeting
LBR/TMPO CAR Ts in vivo.
So I'll conclude by
saying that we think that we've identified that LBR/TMPO bispecific
CAR Ts perform at an enhanced capacity to attenuate tumor burden.
We think that bioinformatics-based discovery platforms are excellent, but they have
limitations. And perhaps there's a role for unbiased subcellular
proteomics that can identify some more context-specific localizations
of proteins that happen in cancer.
And we wonder if this could be a bit of a paradigm shift for target discovery for
very hard to treat cancers, and that maybe we should widen our scope a bit when
looking for new targets.
I want to thank especially Yoo Jin Seok, who I'm very proud to say has matched
in her residency to the University of Toronto for neurosurgery training,
and also to the rest of the medulloblastoma team within the Singh Lab and all of
our wonderful collaborators. Thank you. I'd be happy to take questions.
Sheila.
Hi, John.
Really great. It's a great story.
Thank you.
Beautiful.
I think nuclear envelope proteins normally
traffic through the endoplasmic reticulum, and then they're
transiently in the plasma membrane, then they fall off.
Yes.
And so why are they retained in medullo cells?
So we think it's the patterns of the different fragmentations that
we're seeing, where rather than just being transiently expressed, as
you very correctly say, the literature documents this kind of transient
expression. We're seeing it's almost like it gets lodged there
and aberrantly stays there. And in some of the time-lapse imaging that
we've done, there's
constant waves being thrown up, but once the LBR is stuck there,
it stays there. So-
Is there a function? I mean, is there a neomorphic
function for them in the plasma membrane?
Yeah, that's a fantastic question. We haven't gotten that far.
But of course, there's lots of stories of aberrant
mislocalization of
other proteins in cancer at the plasma membrane.
In this case, the thing that we loved was that it was only in the medulloblastoma
cells and not any normal cells.
Cool. Thank you.
Thank you.
Hi.
Great talk. Really nice data.
Thank you.
So curious. So LBR or other nuclear envelope proteins that
are aberrantly targeted to the plasma membrane, could they be targeted by other
modalities, potentially? Thinking specifically in the context of
medulloblastoma and that it's a pediatric indication.
Absolutely. I mean, we're biased towards CAR T cells in my lab, so
I think we selected the tool that we like and that we have experience with now.
But, I think there are other ways of targeting, and it's important to know I didn't
talk at all about EMINB and the other nuclear envelope proteins.
And in fact, a poly targeting approach might be even better
for this case. And we asked our CAR T cell engineers if they could make
binders for all of them, and they kind of resisted us. So we're working our way.
Thank you.
Hi.
Ian Blumenthal from Seattle Children's Research Institute.
Hi, Ian.
Really fascinating work. Incredible data. Thank you for sharing.
I'm wondering if you have had the opportunity to assess the
plasticity of these aberrant epitopes on the cell surface
when you provide a selective pressure like a CAR T cell.
It's an excellent question. So in the McHale paper, they stress the cells with
doxorubicin. So they put them under chemotherapy stress, and then they
see. Medulloblastoma cells, the ones that we're working with are
already maximally stressed. So they're already
treatment resistant. And so any other stressor, the only other stressor
we're thinking about is hypoxia.
Mm-hmm.
So.
I'm thinking a little bit less about potential additional
metabolic stress, but you're killing cells that are actively
having this aberrant cell surface expression.
Yes.
And so if you're pushing the cells toward
maintaining those epitopes on the nuclear envelope.
Yeah, that's an excellent question and one we need to address experimentally.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Hi.
Hi, John.
Amazing story.
Thank you.
First time I've seen it. So if I understood, you've got like a
tandem CAR with two nanobodies. Have you positioned
those against two respective epitopes in different
parts? Is that how it works?
Yes. And-
And do you need both nanobodies to actually
get-
Yes.
- sufficient binding?
That's an excellent question. So Yoo Jin can share with you all of the different
variations of the experiments she did, but she put them in different orders.
She used different linkers. She actually did pooled CARs as
well, like combined a plain LBR CAR with a TMPO CAR and
treated, and she selected the two best...
The best one was the one that I shared here, but I think she worked through at
least 24 iterations. We used far too many mice.
Right. Great. Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
Our next presenter is Samuel Wu from Stanford
University.He will be giving a talk, Neuronal Activity
Regulated Mechanisms Promote Growth of Diffuse Hemispheric Glioma
H3G34 Mutant.
Hi, good afternoon, everyone. My name is Samuel Wu.
I'm a current third-year undergraduate from the Michelle Monje
Lab at Stanford University. I'm super excited to be
here today for my first ACR and
was surprised and very grateful that my poster abstract
got selected as a mini symposium presentation.
So today, I'll be presenting my work on the
neuronal activity regulated mechanisms that promote the growth of diffuse
hemispheric glioma H3G34 mutant, or
G34 for short.
More broadly, this project asks the larger question of whether
neural activity influences this specific pediatric
high-grade glioma subtype, and through what mechanisms this
occurs, in hopes of finding any translational therapeutic targets.
I have no disclosures.
So the growing field of cancer neuroscience has repeatedly
shown that communication between neurons and glioma cells
to be increasingly important for pediatric glioma
biology. We have learned that neurons can affect gliomas
in various ways, whether it be through growth, through
invasion, initiation, or maintenance, and so forth.
Research in the Monje Lab has better characterized this effect in
certain pediatric high-grade glioma subtypes.
However, as you can see on the right here, pediatric high-grade
gliomas are not all the same, and they are a very
biologically heterogeneous group with distinct
developmental origins, molecular drivers, different
varying ages of
patients, and resulting in wide clinical outcomes.
And that heterogeneity is especially important here because
diffuse hemispheric glioma is now understood to be a
particularly distinct pediatric glioma subtype, as it
appears to arrive from a very unique developmental context than
many other more studied pediatric high-grade gliomas.
And this sets up our main research question, investigating the neuronal
mechanisms behind the devastating G34 mutant
glioma and what has not been
well researched as of yet.
So G34 is a devastating pediatric tumor subtype
that originates from the hemispheres of the brain, as we can see
here. And the median age of diagnosis is
approximately 16 years of age, with a median survival of 17
months. It is defined by the histone 3
G34RV mutation with a unique
developmental origin compared to other histone 3 mutant
pediatric high-grade gliomas, such as
diffuse midline glioma, which is characterized by the K27M
mutation that originates from the brain stem.
Additionally, prior work
suggests that G34 may arise from a distinct developmental
context with a cell of origin that primarily resembles
interneuron lineage cells, and this is also distinct from
the diffuse midline glioma pediatric brain tumor type.
And this has just made us more curious to see whether its
relationship with the neural environment might be different than other pediatric
gliomas.
So first, we asked whether these tumors show any structural evidence of
neuronal intercircuit integration,
and we looked at two GFP positive
patient-derived H3G34 mutant glioma cultures through
hippocampal xenografts. And we noticed that
around 10% of all the synaptic structures
were neuron to glioma synaptic structures through immunoelectron
microscopy
and shows that we identified evidence consistent with direct
neuron to glioma synaptic contacts.
Additionally, we also observed glioma to glioma synapses,
and this was very interesting as it raised the possibility that once
activity enters the tumor network, there is also the potential
for signaling between the tumor cells themselves.
So the overall takeaway from this slide was that G34
showed structural evidence for both neuron to glioma and glioma to
glioma synaptic connectivity.
Of course, structural evidence alone is not enough to
characterize this. So we wanted to ask next,
whether these cells were functionally electrophysiologically active.
And first, we observed evoked excitatory postsynaptic currents, or
EPSCs, meaning that when neural input was deliberately
stimulated, the glioma cells showed a measurable excitatory
output response. And additionally, we also
saw spontaneous electroactivity in the glioma cells
with just a recording electrode in the glioma, which suggests that these
gliomas are actively participating in the network environment.
So taken all together, there is both structural and some
functional evidence about G34 integrating into the neural
circuitry.
So the next question was whether this activity actually was important
for tumor growth. So we co-cultured glioma cells with
neurons and then pharmacologically blocked that activity.
So when we compared glioma cells alone to the glioma cells
grown with neurons, there was an increased proliferation.
But then when we added pharmacological factors such
as TTX, which affects the sodium channels in neurons,
and NBQX, which focuses on blocking
the AMPA receptors for glutamatergic activity-We
found that that neuron-dependent proliferative effect was reduced very close back
down to baseline and just shows us that this growth
advantage provided by neurons is dependent on neuronal
activity.
So then we wanted to shift towards a more in vivo context and see
whether specific forms of neuronal circuit activity were
sufficient to increase G34 growth in mice models.
And we used this optogenetic approach focusing with
channelrhodopsin or ChR2, which lets us to
specifically activate defined neuronal populations with
blue light. And we would stimulate both channelrhodopsin
positive and negative neurons to measure whether that
increase in circuit activity would change glioma proliferation.
So following this timeline in the schematic, we looked at glutamatergic
neuronal activity, and we found that neuronal stimulation
increased tumor proliferation in G34, suggesting
an excitatory circuit activity would be able to promote in
vivo.
And we then also wanted to look at other neuronal populations
and see if that would cause a similar effect as well.
So we looked at GABAergic circuitry, and similarly, we
also saw that there was increased proliferation in result of
the optogenetic
experiments. So a larger takeaway is that
G34 appears to be broadly responsive to these changes in neurocircuit
activity. And even though the glutamatergic and GABAergic
stimulation may act through different mechanisms, both appear to
be capable of enhancing tumor growth in vivo.
Prior studies in other glioma contexts had also shown that
outside of direct synaptic circuit integration, there were
also activity-regulated paracrine factors that could play an
important mechanistic role. And so next we asked whether there
were secreted factors that could transmit part of this proliferative
effect in glioma. And to test that, we used a
conditioned media paradigm, which is we would
stimulate healthy cortical
brain slices with both wild type and channelrhodopsin positive with
patterned blue light.
And
channelrhodopsin-stimulated slices are associated with greater neuronal
activation and paracrine factor secretion
compared to the controls, and this also showed evidence that activity-regulated
factors are sufficient to promote G34 mutant glioma growth.
So at this point, the model becomes a bit more complete with G34
leveraging both circuitry integration and activity-dependent paracrine
signaling. So at this stage, we wanted to know
what secreted activity-regulated mitogens could be causing
this effect. And based on prior work in the lab,
brain-derived neurotrophic factor or BDNF and neuroligin
3 were both natural candidates, as both have been shown to
promote growth in other pediatric gliomas, specifically diffuse midline
glioma, as I mentioned earlier.
However, from our experiments and previously published data in the lab, we do
not see the same effect of these proteins in G34, which
told us something important, that even though this tumor type
seems to respond to neuronal activity, it does not appear to rely on the
same canonical paracrine factors that had been identified previously.
And this fits into the larger biology of the project as a
G34 mutant glioma is shown to be such a
distinct tumor type with a different developmental context and different
cell of origin. So if neural activity still promoted this growth,
there is probably some other activity factor that could be involved.
So this led us to run a proteomic analysis on the conditioned
media, which highlighted
neuronal cell adhesion factor or N-CADHERIN and neurofascin
as two highly upregulated candidate proteins of interest.
So next, we tested these candidates
in proliferation experiments and found that
N-CADHERIN increased proliferation in G34 mutant cells.
And importantly, this was also replicated in additional G34
mutant cell lines, and which shows that these molecules emerge
as a strong candidate as
a possible paracrine factor in this tumor subtype.
And we also wanted to know whether these factors might have
another effect in terms of migration.
So using a spheroid migration assay, we found that neurofascin
increased glioma migration distance over time across various time
points. So altogether, this supports that these proteins
can not only contribute to growth-related effects but also
invasion-related behavior.
And we also began to ask how these proteins might be exerting these effects,
so looking at transcriptional changes induced by N-CADHERIN
treatment. First, this volcano plot here shows that N-CADHERIN
exposure induced a broad change in gene expression with
many genes being upregulated and others being downregulated at the transcriptional
level.
And we also looked through a KEGG analysis.
We saw that there are various upregulated and downregulated changes across
multiple biological programs, specifically
ECM receptor interactions, adhesion, and signaling programs.
And finally,
this focuses on some functional categories that were upregulated
and cell differentiation and neurodifferentiation were some of the most
upregulated biological processes as a result of N-CADHERIN.
So in summary,
some major takeaways is that DHG/HDG34
mutant glioma appears to leverage both conserved and
subtype-specific mechanisms to integrate into
neurocircuitryWe see evidence of synaptic
structures, electrophysiological responsiveness,
activity-dependent growth, and paracrine influences.
And among these factors, NRCam and neurofascin emerge
as strong candidates with effects in both proliferation and
migration for future translational research.
Finally, I'd like to thank the lab, the Michelle Monje lab, as
well as my mentors, Katherine Taylor and Richard Drexler, and the
collaborators at Dana-Farber, with Mira Filbin's lab,
and as well as the undergraduate funding and training programs that made this
work possible. And big thank you to AACR for bringing
me out here and providing me the funding to present this.
And thank you all so much for your attention.
Samuel,
if I may be so bold, future Dr. Wu.
So I have a question. That was a really nice talk for
your debut.
Thank you.
You used these elegant co-culture experiments, xenograft experiments,
cortical slices with conditioned media to try to decipher
a lot of these non-cell autonomous interactions that are very biologically
complex.
Do you feel that there's limitations to not having
in vivo pre-clinical models like GEMs or other things that are limiting
your insights? And are there plans to develop such models?
Yeah, that's a great question. I think in terms
of future things to investigate in an in vivo
context,
there's sort of two branches, I think, with seeing
the integration synaptically with the GABAergic and
glutamatergic activity. There are clinical drugs
out there that
the lab has seen some effect in other pediatric
glioma types. So having some...
Keppra is something that could target GABAergic neuronal
activity, and perampanel is another drug that could
potentially look at glutamatergic brain activity on these.
And then on the other side of the paracrine factor signaling,
some
potential translational things could be looking at using
some sort of drug that targets the downstream changes in
signaling with NRCam and neurofascin, or
some other things that directly target these paracrine factor
proteins.
Super cool that you're an undergraduate and really inspirational.
I'm not that familiar with NRCam, but I was wondering if you guys
knew any putative receptors that could be on the glioma cells, because I
know people have identified neurotransmitter receptors expressed on
GBM. So I was wondering if that was something that you guys were looking into, like
what receptor was mediating this proliferation.
Yeah. That's a great question. Actually, currently, I was working
on doing some phosphoproteomic analyses, so that's sort
of in the process, and hopefully we can see something that these
proteins interact with in the future.
All right. Thank you very much, Samuel.
Thank you.
Our last speaker for this session is Richard Locke
from the Children's Cancer Institute in Sydney, and title of his talk,
"Targeting MIB and REM4
with REM422 for the Treatment of Pediatric T-Cell
Lymphoblastic Leukemia: Report from the Pediatric Preclinical Testing
Consortium ."
Thanks.
I'd like to thank the program committee for
the opportunity to present our data here today.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
This is a pediatric session, so most of you will be familiar with this
introductory slide.
Pediatric ALL is the most common childhood cancer.
The overall cure rates are now around about 90%, and
most of you will be familiar with this type of a graph
from children's oncology
clinical trials since the 1960s that show this
miraculous improvement in cure rates for pediatric ALL,
mainly due to
risk-adapted combination chemotherapy, excellent clinical trials, and
improvements in supportive care.
But the outcomes remain poor for high-risk ALL
subtypes and also for relapse refractory disease.
From another review,
quite recently, you'll see
the outcomes or the survival post first relapse for the
major ALL subtypes, B, T, and infants
is very poor. Moreover, there are some
high-risk B-ALL subtypes,
again, that do exceptionally poor after relapse.
I should add that
these graphs precede the incorporation of blinatumomab into the
treatment of B-ALL. In terms of
T-ALL, when a child or adolescent relapses with
T-ALL, it's generally early, and you can see here
that when a child experiences intermediate or early relapse
with T-ALL, they do exceptionally poorly.
So,
ALL remains one of the most common causes of death from cancer in children, and so
there's still quite a way to go. And just to
also include adult T-ALL, the survival post
relapse for adult T-ALL, again, is dismal.
The pediatric preclinical in vivo testing program has been NCI
funded since 2005 under various guises, the
PPTP and the PPTC. It's now called PIVOT.
Our aim is to generate high-quality in vivo preclinical testing data
for pediatric drug candidates that can be used to inform new agent
prioritization decisions. We currently consist of
seven research programs, six of which are at various
locations within the US. We have been the
ALL testing site since the inception of the consortium.
We're located in Sydney, Australia.
And we also have our coordinating center for data analysis at
Jackson Labs.Changing tack slightly,
MIB
is a lineage-specific dependency in hematologic malignancies.
And just showing some DepMap data here, you can see that there
is a skew towards
myeloid and lymphoid cell lines being dependent on
MIB,
a few colon cancer cell lines as well.
And if you take our pediatric cancer patient-derived
xenografts,
you will see, and look at the RNA-seq data, you will see that the six major
subtypes of ALL here, shown here with the red arrows,
have significantly higher levels of expression of
MIB than the 154 pediatric
solid tumors. So this is 90 ALL PDXs and 154
solid tumors, and the difference is highly significant.
In terms of T-ALL, there can be tandem duplications spanning MIB
at 6q in about 8 to 15% of cases.
There are rarer T-cell receptor beta MIB rearrangements
are observed that juxtapose a T-cell receptor enhancer next to
the MIB gene. There can be somatic mutations that
introduce MIB binding motifs, creating a super enhancer
upstream of the TAL oncogene, and about
30% of MIB wild-type patients have MIB
overexpression.
Now,
many of you will know that
pre-mRNA is processed into RNA and translated into protein, but
about a third of genes can contain a poison exon or a premature
termination codon that when incorporated into the mature
mRNA, results in nonsense-mediated decay and degradation of
the mRNA and loss of the protein.
Now, REM422 promotes poison exon inclusion in the MIB
pre-mRNA, resulting in degradation of MIB RNA and
the protein.
It is a small molecule administered orally once daily.
It's been developed by Remix Therapeutics for the treatment of
AML and high-risk MDS and adenoid cystic
carcinoma, and is in clinical trials, and I believe it may have received FDA
approval for this malignancy just recently.
So it was of interest to us to test REM422
against the pivot
pediatric ALL PDX models.
Just an outline of the study. The aim was to assess the
single-agent efficacy of REM422 against a panel of 30 ALL
PDXs in a single mouse trial using immune-deficient NSG mice.
So we have one vehicle control and one REM422-treated mouse
per PDX.
These are orthotopic models. Human leukemia infiltrates the bone marrow,
spleen, other organs, and disseminates to the peripheral blood.
They're very aggressive, so it's a very high bar to get
efficacy with single agents.
We selected 30 PDXs with different levels of MIB mRNA expression,
and they're shown here on the right, representing the six major subtypes of B-ALL,
Ph-positive, Ph-like, KMT2A rearranged-ALL,
T-ALL, and early T-cell precursor ALL with various levels
of MIB mRNA expression.
REM422 was administered at five milligrams per kilogram daily for
21 days via oral gavage. It was very well tolerated.
Treatments began when individual mice reached 1% human
CD45 cells in the peripheral blood. So this is established disease.
This is about 50 to 60% infiltration of the bone marrow.
It's not developing disease.
The event criteria were when mice reached
25% leukemia cells in the peripheral blood or other ethically
approved endpoints. And the analysis was looking
at leukemia cells in the peripheral blood, event-free
survival, treated minus control, and T over C values, as well as
stringent objective response criteria modeled after the clinical setting.
We took a couple of our PDXs and cultured them ex vivo with
REM422. We have a BCR-ABL positive
PDX and a very aggressive T-ALL PDX.
And you can see when cultured for 24 hours with nanomolar concentrations
of REM422, we get a very nice ablation of
MIB protein levels in these cells. It's almost entirely ablated.
If we then took 250 nanomolar REM422,
you can see that within six hours, we start to see a
downregulation, possibly within two hours, and it's almost completely
gone by 24 hours. So the results of the in vivo testing,
this graph shows
all of the vehicle control in black and all of the
REM422-treated mice with the 30 PDXs.
The gray shaded area is the treatment window, and you can see that
REM422 significantly extended the survival of
these mice to an extent of about 21 days and a T over
C of 2.6. If we then separated the
B-ALLs from the T-ALLs, the controls were pretty much the
same. You can see that the REM422 marginally increased the
event-free survival of the T-ALL group over the B-ALL.
So with the Bs, you have an extension of about 20 days.
With the Ts, it's about 33 days with a T over C of
3.6. And just to illustrate the sort of responses
that we see, these are two PDXs. This is a T-ALL that
achieved and maintained complete response.
You can see we get a prolonged remission in the peripheral blood
well beyond the treatment window.
This is another T-ALL that
achieved and maintained complete response here.
And just to summarize the results of all the PDX, on the left-hand side, we have
swimmer plots, and the black bars represent the vehicle control mice.
The colored bars represent the REM422-treated mice,
colored according to the ALL subtype.
And one of the things I'd like to point out is these T-ALLs are very aggressive.
You can see how quickly the controls reach event, but we get a very nice
extension of mouse event-free survival in the T-ALLs
treated with the REM422. On the right-hand side, we have a waterfall
plot of just the REM422-treated
miceWhere we have plotted out the
maximum decrease in the proportion of human leukemia cells in the peripheral
blood at any point post-treatment initiation.
So if you have a column above zero, that would be progressive disease,
and if you have a column below zero, that would be a remission,
so a decrease in the peripheral blood leukemia blast levels.
And while with the BALLs, we get a pretty much mixed response, I think you can
see that almost all of the TALLs, we get a very deep remission of
response.
Now, I don't expect you to read this table, but I'd just point you towards the
last column of all the results. These are the stringent objective
response criteria modeled after the clinical setting.
And counterintuitively, green is actually the worst response, and red
is the best response. Green is progressive disease, red is a
maintained complete response, and orange is a complete response.
I just want to point out that with the BALLs, we saw four
out of 20 objective responses, but with the TALLs, we saw seven out of 10,
four complete responses, and two MCRs.
So just to summarize, REM422 elicited potent ablation of
MIB protein levels in pediatric ALL PDXs ex vivo.
It was well-tolerated in NSG mice.
We saw significant extensions of mouse EFS
across a broad spectrum of pediatric ALL PDXs.
The objective responses were achieved in seven out of 10 TALL PDXs,
and these results support a potential clinical trial for REM422 in
TALL. I'd like to acknowledge my group at Children's Cancer
Institute for carrying out these studies, all of the pivot
principal investigators and their teams, our colleagues at the coordinating
center at JAX Labs, our colleagues at the NCI,
especially our program director, Malcolm Smith, our colleagues and
staff, patients, and families at Sydney Children's Hospital for the provision of
primary samples to establish the PDXs, our funding agencies,
the NCI and the Australian National Health and Medical Research Council, and
our colleagues at Remix Therapeutics, Charles and Sam, for
provision of REM422, a very interesting and exciting drug for us to
test. Thank you very much.
Richard, really beautiful work. A couple of questions.
Did you look at first of all, how long you retain
the repression of MIB? Do you know, given
after you stop dosing, how long do you still retain MIB repression?
And then what do you know about the models that didn't respond?
Did you get good MIB repression? And then when the disease comes
back, do you have thoughts on resistance yet?
Yeah.
Or did you re-treat, for example?
Yeah. I think this was a Stage 1 study where we took 30
PDXs. We wanted a broad assessment of response,
and those types of studies would be done in a more conventional study where we have
more mice that we can sacrifice and do PD studies, et cetera.
So I don't have answers to any of your questions, and it
really is intriguing to us that with
ALL4, where we would see really nice downregulation of MIB in
vivo, it doesn't really care. So it's not really dependent on MIB.
So I think there's still a lot of work to be done there as to
understand why TALLs might be more dependent than
the BALLs.
Yeah.
Sorry.
It's really exciting, really beautiful work.
Thank you.
Hi. Intriguing. I may have missed it, so apologies if I did, but
what is the risk of creating another poison
exon in other introns and i.e., off-target
effects?
How specific is it?
I probably couldn't answer that question.
I think one of our colleagues from Remix would be able to answer how...
I think it's very specific for MIB.
I don't
believe that it does have off-target effects.
So I don't believe that it would affect other genes that have
poison exons. Yeah.
Richard, one quick question. So in the
REM422, you didn't get
uniform response across all of the T cell PDXs.
Was there any correlation with the perturbation of the MIB locus?
You said that 8% to 15% of them are tandemly duplicated.
Or do you have a skewing of the population of T cell
PDXs that you were studying?
Yeah. It's really intriguing with the TALLs because
if you look at DepMap data, it doesn't appear as though TALL cell
lines are more dependent on MIB than
the BALL cell lines. And also you might think, well, MYC is a
target of MIB, so maybe there's more dependency there.
But even in
MYC, there's no greater dependency for the TALLs than the BALLs.
And I think we've done very elementary studies to
look at
MIB mRNA levels across the
PDXs, and we don't have any kind of biomarker at this point for
why one would respond and another one doesn't.
We
haven't gone back and confirmed that all of those PDXs do have that
poison exon, the ones that respond, and I think there's still a lot more work to be
done there.
Right.
All right. Thank you.
You're
welcome.
Thank you so much to all of the presenters.
This was a really beautiful tour de force of quite a bit of
mechanism to translation and some of the opportunities we have.
I thought I'd just contextualize a little bit where we are and where we could go if
we sort of explode the system a little bit.
Obviously, we've come a long way with pediatric cancers.
But as you can see from this image on the right, we have a
ways to go, right? Until this number is 100% across all of these tumor
types, we really haven't achieved our goal.And to me, what
that means is that we're at a precipice of being able to
unlock a lot of opportunity, and I think that is because of
the real explosion of technology that we can apply to
patients.
This is adapted from a review article we just wrote about
specifically CNS tumors, CAR T cell therapies, and how we think
about reverse translation in that platform.
But you can see even in just this one location, there are so many
different assays we can apply,
and I think there are so many pieces of data we can accumulate.
But the real question to me is not we can accumulate a lot of
data, but how do you ask the right question with the data you're accumulating, and
how do you put the right lens on that data so that you can
actually understand the drivers of resistance, response,
and durable activity of any of our therapies that we're giving in the world?
This is specific to CAR T cells because that's where I live, but
I've adapted it to the talks today.
So right, we can think about tumor intrinsic complications,
unique biological drivers that actually are the driving
force of why the tumors are so resistant, so difficult
to treat. We can think about tumor heterogeneity, which is a huge problem when you
do anything in a targeted therapy fashion.
We can think about mechanisms of the tumor immune environment, thinking
about the T cells, where they colocalize, what they're doing.
We've heard about metabolic
and neuronal crosstalks today, and so I think there's an entire
opportunity of learning how these things interface with each other in the context
of treatment response and response failure.
And then finally, the treatments themselves have intrinsic flaws that result
in therapy failure. So understanding how do we get T cells to infiltrate into
tumors, for example, in CAR T cells, how do we make them function in the tumors?
How do we allow for durable functional activity?
I think these are the questions that we can ask with the assays if we use them in
the smartest and best ways.
I think the reality is we can get all the data we want from patients, but in order
to understand the mechanistic implications of that information, we have to be able
to model it in the lab. And there are many models that exist
in this space of
basic research, and I think each of them, all models, what I tell my lab is all
models are bad models, but all models are actually good models if you know their
limitations and their strengths.
And so using the right models to answer your question as you
get this data from patients, I think is going to be really important to
understand what drives function and what drives resistance.
And so to me, the combination of the very high dimensional
data that we can accumulate, as has been seen in these presentations today,
and the modeling in the lab is really going to be the mechanism of
unlocking therapies. And as we all know, there are now five
pillars of therapy that we can use in our patients, and the reality is
no one of these is going to work independently.
And so the better that we can understand every individual one of these and
how we combine them, I think the more we can actually unlock durable
responses and hopefully cures for our pediatric patients.
With that, I'd like to thank you all for your time,
and thank you for the session.